aussitôt acheté aussitôt sur le marché
que ce soit des maisons des condos des
immeubles à logements les reventes
rapides ont plus que doublé depuis 2000
16 dans le grand montréal et se sont
accélérées pendant la pandémie
l'an dernier 2008 100 propriétés ont
changé de mains deux fois en moins de 12
mois
quelqu'un qui fait peu de maisons voire
va faire son profit sur deux éléments un
sur la valeur ajoutée qui va racheter la
propriété est aussi le temps que ça
vaille prononcée par un enfer c'est très
beau mais pendant ce temps là l
accroissement de la valeur du marché
en rénovant leurs propriétés il espère
dégager des profits qui surpasseront
leurs investissements un jeu qui peut
être lucratif
vous avez des des retours sur
investissement d'à peu près 80% pour les
jeunes femmes bien alors que le prix
médian des maisons unifamiliales a
grimpé de 13 pour cent dans l'ensemble
l'an dernier il a bondi de 39%
c'est à dire trois fois plus pour les
propriétés qui ont fait l'objet d'une
revente rapide
comment un petit coup un petit coup
d'argent mais aussi on a les gens qui
vivent d'autres complètement même si le
nombre de reventes rapide a grandement
augmenté il demeure somme toute assez
marginal la cause fondamentale de la
flambée des prix actuels demeurent
l'important déséquilibre entre l'offre
et la demande en raison de la pandémie
plusieurs propriétaires de maisons ont
décidé de reporter la vente de leur
propriété
mais en même temps le bassin d'acheteurs
lui s'est agrandie lorsque le produit
était à pêcher pilotes au monde qu'ils
étaient confinés dans les petits espaces
à l'inversion 10 sont en train de
s'étrangler plus grand des ventes
donc c'est sûr que certaines personnes
qui sont définies par an trois fuites si
le nombre de transactions a baissé dans
le grand montréal en juin
comparativement à l'an dernier le nombre
de propriétés mises en vente a diminué
encore plus résultat les prix ont grimpé
de près de 30% en un an
il se lie vieux machins réseau canada
montréal